um anyway and did you when you ask when
you say lifeguard that's that's a very
nice um example because I would think
that
um when I'm trying to make anyways is
when you apply for any job role
is there do you see but like if you say
you want to become a lifeguard for
instance and you see it on indeed do you
see
um lifeguard role women salary 10 pounds
an hour men's salary 15 pounds an hour
or do you see lifeguard rule 10 pounds
an hour and whoever gets hired gets that
salary usually says from pending on
experience or something like that well
okay then then that would come to
negotiation power that has nothing to do
with it um well my other question is why
don't we talk about the women models get
paid more than mailbox first everyone
where is the marches
right someone causes the cost so the
reason why that women and it works the
other way around too so the reason why
women don't tend to be in male-dominated
Industries as much is just because it's
unpleasant it's saying for the reason
why men don't women women don't want to
do hard jobs